what did my mom's showing let's just
let's just get some Monday hey everyone
I'm Abby short welcome to Abby's kitchen
today's what I eat in a day youtuber few
is of Kate flowers now Kate actually
reached out to me about a month or so
ago after she saw my freely response
video and she told me all about her
experience coming out as no longer
fruitarian and all of the bullying that
she had endured which I really can
empathize with so Kate told me that she
actually had a new wedding add a video
coming out and she would have loved for
me to review it so I took a little
look-see at her channel I've learned
that she's a dancer and she's a
beautiful dancer at that she also used
to be fruitarian and raw but now she's
incorporating some more cooked foods
into her diet but she is completely
plant-based so without adieu let's get
to it it's kind of a specialty treat for
me I don't have it all the time because
it's really really pricey but when I do
you have it I enjoy it so I love that
all these youtubers are talking about
staying hydrated in the morning it's so
so important and I always poke fun at
the whole green juice thing in the
morning with a lot of these youtubers
and so I think it's funny that she even
mentioned that but I have no qualms with
green juice or coconut water any time of
day
morning noon night whatever however they
are no substitute for the og of
hydration water coconut water and green
juice has of course calories has carbs
so you don't want to substitute all the
fluids in your day for that otherwise
those those carbs and those calories are
really gonna start to add up and unless
you are exercising for a prolonged
period of time in the heat you probably
don't need the added electrolytes of
coconut water so you can probably skip
that most often and save the cash but as
a nice treat to switch things up by all
go for it okay so let's take a look at
her breakfast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that looks delicious
eh and I've been watching a lot of these
what I eat in a day videos now and I
don't know if it's like a mom thing that
I finally realized this or what and the
fact that nowadays I often have to
choose between like a hot meal and a hot
shower but does anyone actually have
time to make themself a smoothie bowl
and then assemble it all pretty like
that on their rustic wooden photography
board with a pale blue linen anyone like
I want to live that life no but I'm just
teasing you girl I hope you can like
laugh along with me here but seriously I
I find like a lot of these smoothie
bowls and breakfasts and what I need
days are like really unrealistic in real
life I definitely don't have time to do
that kind of stuff anymore
maybe like three years ago I would have
or at least I would have pretended to
but nowadays I have totally realized
that real life is not always
instagram-worthy
as for the smoothie itself totally YUM I
love the color it looks beautiful it
looks super hydrating refreshing I also
am obsessed with ham parts I put the
hose on everything I love them because
they're a great source of omega-3s and
protein however I probably would have
liked to see a little bit more protein
in the morning maybe some nut butter in
there or some vegan protein powder or
maybe some silken tofu or something like
that
but in general I think it's a really
yummy breakfast I thought the music
choice was like kind of great very
appropriate it felt like very Zen very
very uplifting airy it was a nice way to
start your day to kind of ease into it
and it was like exactly what I would
expect one to listen to while eating a
smoothie bowl
has digestive issues following some type
of food combining can be really helpful
and therefore you're gonna want to have
fruit in the morning I'm gonna stop Kate
right there for a second because I want
I was a that's a unfortunate screenshot
I'm sorry Kate you're so beautiful so
that I apologize for that let's talk
about food combining for a hot minute so
this is a theory that eating certain
foods together or not eating them
together can impact our digestion
because advocates believe that because
we have different enzymes today just
proteins and different enzymes to digest
carbohydrates that consuming them
together can lead to digestive distress
as Kate is referring to if you have
digestive issues however our body is so
much more sophisticated than that and
research is not being able to prove
prove that there's any health benefits
to food combining in reality our enzymes
actually can break down a variety of
foods at the same time and in my opinion
eating foods together can actually do a
lot of good it can boost the nutrition
of our meals
it can mace make foods more satiating it
can stabilize our blood sugars so for
example I always recommend having some
form of protein or fat to pair with our
carbohydrates to help stabilize our
blood sugars
I also recommend always having some kind
of fat with your fat soluble vitamins
which are often found in your vegetables
that's going to enhance the absorption
of those fat soluble vitamins so that's
actually why I usually recommend we do
some food combining because it's in a
lot of cases can optimize the nutrition
in your meal so I say fruit is healthy
any time of day have it in the morning
have it at night whenever it feels great
for your body new song
[Music]
the photography boards back guys we're
gonna eat all meals there from now on
so that looks super delicious and Kate's
calling this like a mock potato salad
but I don't think there's a need to call
it a mock potato salad cuz it looks just
like a really tasty salad in its own
right it's got lots of antioxidants lots
of great fat lots of fiber I'm loving it
I also don't want people to think that
potatoes are bad they are not they get
such a bad reputation
unnecessarily potatoes are such a great
source of vitamin C potassium resistance
starch fiber and actually I've got a
whole video debunking potato myths right
here so this is a really easy tasteless
inexpensive way for me to get that I
just usually add it to one savory meal a
day so I'm really happy that Kate's
talking about iodine iodine so really
important mineral um it helps our
thyroid gland produce thyroid hormone
which is imperative for everything from
brain health to metabolism and so many
other body processes so we get our
iodine from seafood dairy products
seaweed dried prunes and iodine
fortified salt and I don't recommend
that people go ahead and like eat more
salt as a way to get their iodine we
most North Americans should probably be
cutting back on their salt so these kelp
granules are a really great low salt way
for vegans to get their fix
simple protein shake it's not like a
smoothie or anything there's not any
frozen bananas or fruit in here it's
simply just almond milk protein powder
and three tablespoons of hemp seeds I'm
obsessed with hemp seeds because of
their nutritional benefits there's just
lots of minerals and omega-3s and good
stuff in hemp seeds so I have lots of
hemp seeds
I also added in some ice cubes so that
it's nice and cold because that frozen
bananas it won't be and nobody once a
warm shake agreed
nobody wants a warm shake so great
little simple snack also bridges the gap
between lunch and dinner nicely
especially because her lunch wasn't
super high in protein I'm also speaking
her language on the hemp heart love I
put that on everything so I agree Kate
they are like a superfood and I don't
use that term very much but I love them
[Music]
[Music]
okay this giant bowl of soup is still
steaming and really hot so I'm gonna
just wait a minute before I taste it
because I don't want to burn my tongue
so this recipe is incredibly easy to
make all you do is blend together all of
the ingredients except for the broccoli
and it becomes like a thick kind of
soupy broth liquid and then pour that
into a saucepan add the broccoli and
bring it to a slight boil and then cover
it and let it simmer for five six
minutes until the broccoli is soft and
then new so easy so loving the soup idea
I love soup for dinner I'm a big I'm a
big food person in general and that one
looks amazing I love the color I love
the antioxidants it's got protein it's
got Omega threes it's got B vitamins
including the big one b12 which I you
know a lot of vegans have a hard time
getting enough of so I'm definitely
making that so in terms of our
macronutrient distribution my numbers
came out a little bit higher than hers
but I have her at 49 percent of her
calories coming from carbohydrates 32
percent of our calories coming from fat
and 19 percent of her calories coming
from protein which is very generally
healthy balanced diet so in the video
Kate also breaks down her micronutrient
and macronutrient distribution in quite
a lot of detail and I can appreciate
that those of you who might start a new
diet like a vegan diet that's
restrictive may seem or or feel that
having that raw data in front of you is
really really useful in helping you to
fill in those nutritional gaps and
helping you to like plan out your meals
in your menu however where it starts to
become problematic is where it
interferes with your ability to eat
intuitively and listen to your body and
have a healthy happy relationship with
food so I just want to flag that that
that's not really behavior that I would
encourage people to do every single day
or every single meal because it can
really start to interfere with your
ability to listen to your body okay so
let's talk about Kate's channel in
general and I'd love to talk about what
I like about it first of all she's
responsible about her expertise I love
that she has
disclaimer at the beginning of her video
thank you thank you so much for being
responsible about your authority in the
space too many youtubers are out there
making outlandish nutrition claims and
insisting that their diet is the only
way that you should eat and that is
really what has led me down this rabbit
hole to begin with so thank you thank
you thank you thank you for knowing and
and acknowledging your knowledge gaps
and your role here number two she's
honest and responsible about her journey
so over the years Kate has been a very
forthcoming in her videos talking about
the shifts in her diet going from a
hundred percent raw vegan and fruitarian
to enjoying more cooked foods and fat
and protein in her diet and it seems
like just looking at the comments
section in her videos that her followers
are really enjoying this honesty and the
direction that her channel is going as I
mentioned at the top of the video she
also recently opened up about no longer
being fruitarian and basically talking
about how it just was no longer serving
her health well and it was not
sustainable and she actually went back
and pulled and and removed all videos
that contain potentially problematic
information so thank you thank you thank
you Kate that was a super responsible
and I'm sure very challenging move to
make but it really really is amazing
that you're putting your followers
health first and helping to transition
the community to a healthier happier
place finally I love that she has really
easy accessible plant-based recipes I
love that the ingredients were not super
expensive or crazy hard to find or
exotic they're quite accessible I mean
that soup just had like a handful of
ingredients so I'm totally making it
this week okay so let's talk about what
I don't love so much
first of all she's still mainly raw so
yes her dinner is cooked and that's
great but most of her meals are either
raw or in liquid form so smoothie shake
soup I've discussed this before but
there's really no good evidence to
suggest that there's any benefits of a
raw food diet and there's no evidence to
suggest that there's any health issues
associated with consuming cooked foods
with their enzymes denatured by heat we
have our own enzymes to process and
digest food so that's really great so
while some water-soluble nutrients like
vitamin C and a can be reduced in the
cooking processes other really important
antioxidants like by the carotene or
lycopene are actually enhanced by
cooking so cooking food in a lot of
cases can increase nutrient absorption a
digestion and of course add flavour so
examples of foods that are best raw from
a nutrient perspective are things like
broccoli cabbage onions and garlic
basically whole foods that you probably
don't want to eat raw unless you live
and sleep alone and don't mind farting
all night long
so examples of foods that are best
cooked are things like asparagus spinach
tomatoes carrots legumes potatoes and of
course animal products
gaudí do not get me shiny bunnies and
then finally there's a heavy emphasis on
numbers so it definitely made my
calculations a lot easier but I've
talked about this briefly before and I'm
sure you know a lot of her followers
find these numbers really useful but
they can also be super triggering for
those of us who you know are trying to
reconnect with our body and learn how to
focus on intuitive eating but what I'm
most impressed about Kate and her
channel is the transparency Kate is a
responsible influencer and that is a
rarity especially in the vegan YouTube
space where let's be real there's a lot
of misinformation and a lot of people
peddling bad nutrition information
without any qualifications so thank you
so much Kate for being that responsible
person and I will continue to follow
your journey and follow along with your
channel so guys I hope you enjoyed this
video if you did be sure to give it a
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
some ideas for other youtubers that
you'd like me to review I'm also really
looking for some non vegan ones as well
right now so if you have any ideas send
them my way subscribe to the channel and
don't forget to watch this amazing
playlist with more great what a user
gamers
see you next time bye
[Music]